I thank you very much for that
introduction everyone really appreciated
that we will get the meeting started uh
with an opening prayer today
we come to you with our thankful hearts
for bringing us together today as we
prepare to meet together I ask that you
fill each of our hearts with your
presence help us use the time we have
together wisely I ask that you would
remind us to place one another's needs
above your own please remove any selfish
gain from Among Us and help us to seek
the good of those around us
right
may we be quick to hear and slow to
speak may we be slower to take
offense and quick to show Grace and
forgiveness May our speech be seasoned
with salt and our hearts filled with
grace we pray amen
please be seated
foreign
just before we get underway today given
the significance of this council meeting
I
just wanted to go through a few things I
just want to thank each and every one of
you for coming here today I really
appreciate the support I know that the
council as a whole does it is great to
see everyone so active in democracy
welcome back to the media and hello and
welcome if this is your first time
I just want to go through some safety
measures here today because there are so
many of us in this building
if it is to get unruly at the back I
will stand up and ask for silence
that will be the first warning if it is
to happen again I will stand up and
myself and the counselors will exit the
room and we'll have a 10 minute
admission until everything cools back
down again
does that sound good with everyone
fantastic love that
first up on the agenda apologies
looks like we're all here thank you very
much any Declarations of counselor
conflicts of interest
doesn't seem to be any
item number three ministerial
intervention
would Council Havel like to speak to
this motion
your worship I would like to move that
the council work with local government
New Zealand and taitara to develop and
amended terms of reference for an
independent review to restore confidence
in the council
thank you councilor I would be more than
happy to second that would anyone like
to speak to that motion
is the Mover I would like to speak first
I stood for Council in order to serve to
benefit the community
to promote economic social development
for the benefit of not only the people
who are here today but for all those who
live in Gore in the surrounding areas
I'd hope to work together with others
with the people around the table with
the wider community and with all elected
representatives
however that has been compromised by
poor behaviors and a lost loss of trust
around the table
people who know me know that I'm
conservative
they know that I am averse to
confrontation
so for me to be part of a group of
people who are speaking out on this
raises I hope for the people who do know
me that there are some serious issues
that need to be addressed
some of the messaging I've received says
the me has been elected and let them get
on with it
however the consequences of not calling
out bad behaviors is allowing them to
flourish
we have tried to resolve matters
internally on a number of occasions
without success so it is time to speak
out
others in the Press have said stop
behaving like children I would say the
opposite
El mental and physical health is at risk
what do you want us to do pretend all is
well and carry on that is no longer the
New Zealand way
in recent months I've tried to help
steer through some difficulties but they
still remain
I don't want a community of whispering
with us acting as though there's nothing
wrong when it is when there is I prefer
to share openly with the community with
the issues that are before us
because that is who we represent
and in the spirit of openness I wish to
talk to the meeting that was organized
on Friday of last week where most of the
council has met with the Department of
internal affairs
the mayor and councilor McKenzie were
not invited to that meeting and it was
my responsibility to ensure that they
were told about the meeting while it was
being held and the reason why they
hadn't been invited I didn't do that it
was my responsibility and I apologize to
both of you
I understand that the department has
since been in contact with the mayor
many people have contacted me and other
counselors over the last few weeks
there's been new mayors old Mays retired
Mayors councilors from other councils
lawyers there's even been a priest who's
contacted me government agencies and
local government New Zealand
we the elected representatives have
considered the advice in the comments
that we have received and that has
resulted in submitting a new resolution
to today's meeting
the intent of the original resolution
was to find a way forward in a formal
way
now what is proposed in the advice that
we have received from many sources is
that there are better ways to do that
and that is the reason for tabling a new
motion today it is actually wider in
scope than what was originally intended
not only to look at the relationship
between the councilors between each
other sitting here at the table today
but also between the councilors and the
mayor and between us as the elective
representatives and the staff and The
Wider community
I see on the news today and have been
advised that my name is part of a
petition that has been entered into
Council on several other councilors
their names appear on that petition as
well I've given no Authority for my name
to be used and it concerns me that the
petition is being used in this way
finally to the community I say if you
want us to move forward then help us
it's not helpful to read many of the
things that are on social media it
doesn't help the mental and physical
health of us as counselors the staff in
the building and many people in The
Wider Community please can we work
together thank you
thank you councilor I will reserve my
right of reply if there is any further
comment from counselors
counselor Richard mcvale
yes uh thank you you worship just a um
probably a statement of support in
regard to councilor hovel
um I've said here before in previous
meetings and
we continually came back to the trust
confidence and integrity
circumstances that we found ourselves in
I say we because I now say that the
council which includes the worship is
worship and the council is sitting
around the table
we need to act in the best interests of
our community not ourselves
we need to reflect in the past weeks
the various resolutions that were passed
at meetings
we've gone and ever decreasing circles
in the hope of change
and now we're here today
we do not have the skills to correct
some of our issues and we do need
assistance
we've seen and reflected on in the past
weeks
and in more recent days
communication which has occurred
which I believe isn't a common sense
approach
to the issue that we have before us or
the issues we're facing
and as described in the recent Sunday
program the Galway
it saddens me to see the media portrayal
of Gore but we have the opportunity
and the will to reset ourselves as a
council
when we look at some of those
resolutions
and what's happening within the
community
we need to
re remind ourselves that one of our
River resolutions was to support the
council staff and the CEO
now we are employers
and we need to remind ourselves of the
legislation and the requirement around
the fact that the council include the
councilors and his worship our employers
I believe the recent events that have
occurred in the last couple of weeks
have always caused to to give us a
circuit breaker
and the way that we deal with the
resolutions today is the first step to
rebuilding that trust and confidence of
the community and us not the other way
around
I'll close with challenging times and
Times of uncertainty they test character
but we're still all here today
and this itself shows the commitment
that we all have for our community
thank you
thank you for that counselor
councilor Dixon
thank you worship
I have respect for the public here today
and they're standing up for democracy
and I have the greatest respect for
their other councilors sitting around
this table and the staff who are present
here today
the last few months have been stressful
and challenging
we stood for Council not because we've
got big Egos and we wanted to get rich
we stood to represent our community in a
community that we care about
we make tough decisions based on being
fully informed to the best of our
ability for the community as elected
members and an example of the items on
the is one of the items on the agenda
today
I recognize that the current situation
is unsustainable and there needs to be
movement between the parties to help
this Council work effectively which
ultimately is in the best interests of
the community
I did sign the requisition to invite Ben
to resign as the impasse was too great
and the stress for all parties was
overwhelming including the mayor
it was more a cry for help than anything
else its Council was hamstrung
Ben we are your allies allies sorry
we're not your enemies and I believe we
had dug some trenches but we're stepping
out to move forward with you
a role now is to support you and the
council to allow you to be the best
possible me that you can and for the
council to be the best possible Council
that we can
for this Sublime District so therefore I
support this recommendation
wholeheartedly thank you
thank you for that counselor
was there any further comment from any
other counselor councilor there Guardian
is I support this person and I didn't
sign the requisition but I felt coming
to a council meeting and discussing it
and having it out in the open is what we
need to do we need to reset and forgive
each other
move forward and support
the staff and the mayor and the CEO
going forward and it has to be a team
effort and that is my
point I think where we have had a good
discussion together and I think we are
on that track
thank you
thank you councilor
any further comment from any other
Council counselor Reed
thank you
um I will support councilor herbal
councilor mcphail and auto councilors
Dixon's comments so far every one of us
is here to do the best we can for our
community and going forward I will give
my commitment to honor that commitment
my word to honor that commitment
thank you councilor
any further comment from any other
counselor
counselor Paul mcphail
I also support the comments that have
just been made by all the other
councilors and I'll support the motion
thank you councilor with the oh
councilor Phillips
thank you your worship I also support
the motion that's been brought forward
by uh councilor hoveau in regards to
that uh the people who know me I've
served in this community in various
organizations for over 50 years and um
I'm here to represent not only the
matter award but also the district and I
shall hope to carry on doing so
thank you councilor to the three
remaining councilors have anything to
say
Council Stringer
I'd also like to support that
motion that's been put forward by the
councilor of Elder and Baker thank you
Sonic now yeah I support the motion as
well we need to put the past issues
behind us and move forward for the good
of of the gore District that we all
serve as councilors thank you
thank you councilor and Council McKinsey
uh three you worship I want to say
it has been a very stressful exercise
for all of us
I mean most I I support the mayor I mean
I do know we all support them here in
different ways
and I can see the potential here to
build a bloody good team of people
to do a bloody good job excuse my
Expressions but that's the way I talk
I support the motion
and I think
possibly we do need some assistance
but let's build a good team thank you
[Applause]
thank you councilors I really appreciate
uh all of the comments around the table
I I took note of it of a few and wanted
to express some of my feelings over the
last couple of days
I think getting the request to resign
was was probably two of the darkest days
of my life it was incredibly hard it was
incredibly stressful
but following that
um the immense pressure from the
community and the voice helped Lift Me
Up
but in sequently pushed all our
counselors down and I believe that they
had some of the the hardest days of of
their lives I would imagine
I think that brings us to some of the
points the councils have made here today
a number of councils said we need the
skills to help us I I could not agree
more
I'm not perfect I hate to say it but but
all of us counselors aren't perfect
either we've all made mistakes and we're
at the point now where we need some
desperate help from
the the professionals the people who do
this day in and day out to help us out
to maneuver through this
councilor mcphail said that we need to
return to the Galway and I I completely
and wholeheartedly agree uh we're we're
not the town that is meant to be in the
headlights all the time we will leave
that to Auckland and Wellington but down
here we want to get on with the Galway
and that's ultimately the South and low
which is just getting on with the job
councilor Dixon talked about democracy I
want to thank everyone here and the
people all across the country who have
got involved over the last couple of
days to stand up for democracy I
wholeheartedly appreciate it and I'm
sure our electoral system appreciates it
too
we've been making I feel that councils
have been making decisions to the best
of their abilities as was mentioned
before
But ultimately we need help to save what
those decisions should be
I wholeheartedly agree with councilor
McKenzie that we have real potential
here to come together to reunite and to
find a way forward and what a Redemption
story it will be
so I second the motion if there's no
further comments I will put the motion
all those in favor please say aye
and against the motion is carried thank
you councilors
make sure I haven't skipped right here
item number four vote of no confidence
the recommendation that sits here is the
cap that the council pass a vote of no
confidence in the mayor Benjamin Bell
did we have a mover
no we didn't
then we shall move on if there is no
further discussion
[Applause]
thank you very much uh legal opinion to
remove the mayor from the chief
executive appraisal committee
uh did we have anyone who would like to
speak to the report
no I will take the reporters read
I with with this being such a public
story I've received uh all sorts of of
legal advice from throughout the country
um
but as this recommendation says it's
that the report
and legal opinion from Anderson Lloyd be
received and noted
um I don't feel like it's appropriate to
argue and hear whether that opinion is
correct
so I think
that we should receive and note it if
there is no further discussion on this
topic
councilor Hotel a point of order your
worship and we need to move a first and
a second hour in order to discuss it
granted do we have a mover
councilman actor now a seconder
councilor Stringer
discussion would you like to kick us off
at Council bill
do we have any other discussion on the
Council of Richmond fire
yes thank you worship obviously the
question in regard to noting uh
receiving the the legal documentation
the indication was when we we discussed
this in a previous meeting was in regard
to whether the question was asked
whether you were going to remain on the
appraisal committee
um so probably I have to in light of
that ask whether you intend to stay on
the appraisal committee for the CEO
thank you councilor uh given the legal
advice as it stands and considering
there is seems to be no discussion about
debasing it I buy the legal opinion and
removed from there I would like to
explain to the councils and also to the
public that my reason for wanting that
legal opinion uh is in relation actually
to the next one um I don't believe it is
it is fair or right that Emir should be
removed from all of his committees
um as for
[Applause]
as for the chief executive appraisal
committee we talked a lot about Unity
here today I don't want to be a thorn in
the side of that appraisal committee
um so I'm more than happy to acknowledge
this league of advice and and step away
from that committee
[Applause]
um did we have any further discussion
councilor Richmond uh Justin replied
that you worship I believe that probably
it would be a pertinent for me to
withdraw from the
um
CEO's appraisal committee as well due to
the fact that I've been an intermediary
between both of you I know it doesn't
have to uh voted on but I think it
should be passed and noted in the
minutes that I'll be standing down from
that
[Applause]
thank you for that counselor and I think
that's in line with the first resolution
that we passed around getting some
advice from alginson and Thai Twitter
about where to from here
do we have any further discussion on
this item
no I will put the motion all those in
favor please say aye
and against the motion is carried
thank you councilors
the last item on this agenda is that the
council removed the mayor from the
following sub from the following
committees subcommittees and joint
committees as its infrastructure
committee audit and risk committee
Community well-being committee policy
and Regulatory committee rural halls and
domain subcommittee District plan
subcommittee Great South joints
shareholder committee Southland waste
Advisory Group waste net Southland civil
defense Emergency Management Group
do I have a mover for that motion
no
no the motion lapses and that brings us
[Applause]
thank you very much for all of your
attendance we will be taking a slight
into mission in between meetings if you
want to stick around and hear about our
Bridge Project or Innovative streets or
all sorts of other things that we'll be
discussing feel free to rejoin us at 4pm
but this meeting is officially closed
thank you very much